Something that I think few people appreciate is that when you use a hand
sanitizer, before you go shopping,
and then you touch the store register receipt,
these store register receipts are actually coded with bisphenol a,
which is a pretty potent endocrine disruptor that hand sanitizer,
when you use it just before,
or even just after you touched these receipts that actually dramatically,
by at least an order of magnitude increases the permeability of your skin to
these compounds.
I'm noticing now at whole foods,
just because we're in the midst of this odd thing with Corona virus,
that nobody, at least at my whole foods,
nobody's touching the grains that you can do yourself. You know,
they've got that wall of grains. It's like,
nobody's even going over there anymore,
which is probably I guess good at the moment, but you know, who does?
Yeah. A lot of people are now using these hand sanitizers. If you like,
go on Amazon, it's there, the markup has just shot up exponentially.
Um, but something that I think few people appreciate is that when you use a hand
sanitizer, before you go shopping,
and then you touch the store register receipt,
the store register receipts are actually coded with bisphenol a,
which is a pretty potent endocrine disruptor that hand sanitizer,
when you use it just before,
or even just after you touched these receipts that actually dramatically,
by at least an order of magnitude increases, um,
the permeability of your skin to these compounds. So you want to be you,
I don't know.
Well, that's incredible.
They were literally selling hand sanitizer at the register.
You probably people are buying it right then and there you put it on,
you grab the receipt now. Okay.
Yeah. It's not good. Um, that's actually a big topic that I cover in, uh,
in the new book is, um, endocrine disruption and environmental toxins without,
uh, trying to fearmonger, but just to kind of alert people, um,
and to get people to think a little bit more critically about, uh,
the industrial chemicals to which they are routinely exposed.
All right. So before we go fully there,
I want to tell you what my basic diet is on a day like today,
where I told you right before we sat this last time,
we didn't do this last time. And I think I was doing pretty good,
but on a day like today, I'm having, I have a crazy day. I have,
I told you I have two shoots.
Then I have three other shows and we're doing a live stream.
Like I'm going to be just crazed all day long. So this morning, uh,
all I've had so far today, it's about 10:00 AM right now. I had a cup of coffee.
You know, I grind the beans myself, do that.
I put a scoop of collagen protein in there and a half teaspoon of lion's
mane mushroom, which is good for the brain, as they say,
I've had that one cup and I've had, um, about, uh,
three quarters of a cup of oatmeal with a little almond milk and a tiny bit of
sugar-free syrup. And that's going to get me to lunch.
How am I doing in the morning?
It sounds pretty good. Pretty good.
It's just it's college in proteins. So it's like maybe 18 grams of protein.
Something like that is not. Yeah. Talk to me about college.
This is LA everybody's obsessed with college and you can't go anywhere with
that.
I'm actually a fan of college. College is one of the few,
especially today where we tend to eat for the omnivores in the audience.
We tend to eat mostly muscle meat,
which is concentrated in an amino acid called methionine an essential amino
acid.
But there is thinking that by consuming too much methianine without adequate
glycine,
which is an amino acid that is found predominantly in collagenous tissue and
also in college and protein. It's about one third of one,
third of collagen protein is glycine. Um, that that might be to our detriment.
So especially for an omnivore,
I think supplementing with college and protein is actually a pretty good idea.
Um, so.
So coffee with a little college and protein and some of the mushroom powder I'm
doing okay in the morning.
Fan of, of lion's mane as well. I use, uh, you know, the lion's mane powder.
I think it's, um, they've the studies on lion's mane. It,
it can potentially boost, uh, nerve growth factor. And I've seen,
there was a clinical trial performed in Japan where it's been used to, uh, they,
they, what they observed was a,
a boost in cognitive function in patients with mild cognitive impairment. So,
um, you know, I'm a fan of these, uh,
these like quote unquote medicinal mushrooms.
There's not a ton of research on them, but.
Right. And then oatmeal, little sugar-free syrup I'm doing okay. Yeah. Oatmeal.
So common milk.
It's a little for me,
it's a little high-glycemic to have first thing in the morning, but, uh,
oatmeal, you know, it's a great source of soluble fiber it's satiating. Um,
you've got these beta glucans in it, which are immunomodulatory. Um, so yeah,
I think oatmeal is a steel cut is generally the best it's going to have the
lowest.
They're still cutting. You can confirm,
you can confirm when you walk out of here. Okay.
So then I'll have two shows and then I'm going to have lunch.
I think they placed the order already.
We're doing like sweet greens or tender greens, like a Chipotle,
a chicken salad romaine. There's probably a little cheese in there.
I'm a big fan of them.
But I, I eat what's called a big fatty salad every day.
I feel like I might've talked about this the last time I was here, but yeah,
researchers at rush university, actually one of the research, one of the, the,
the lead author in a lot of the studies that I use, um,
that I cite in, in my, in my books, in my, and in my talks,
Martha Clare, Morris, she just passed away of a soft GL cancer. Um,
she is the originator of the mind diet,
and she also has done a lot of the epidemiology surrounding, um, you know,
risk factors for cognitive decline. And what she found,
what her team found is that the consumption of a big salad every day about a cup
and a third of dark leafy greens is associated with brains that perform up to 11
years younger. So yeah, I mean, there's probably a strong,
healthy user bias there too. Um, people who eat more greens, more whole grains,
things like that tend to be more health conscious, but, uh, you know,
we know that dark leafy greens are good for us. They contain carotinoids,
which are really beneficial for iHealth, for brain health. Okay.
You can eat a lot of spinach really quick,
cause you can put a whole handful of it. And once it cooks down,
it's like three bites and you're good.
Yeah. Spinach. Yeah. I'm a fan of dark leafy greens. I mean,
we live in this weird contentious time in,
in nutrition where we've got these different factions, like breaking off,
we've got the vegans, we've got the carnivores. Um, and so I, you know,
I actually have a pretty balanced message. I think I, uh,
I'm a strong advocate of the consumption of animal foods, grass fed beef,
fatty fish, things like that. Um, but then also, yeah, dark leafy greens, kale,
spinach, arugula.
So speaking of the carnivores, you know,
I was on tour with Jordan Peterson and he became famous or infamous for
partaking in the carnivore diet,
which I think his daughter Mikayla has now called the lion lion, the lion diet,
which is quite literally only beef. I mean, and I was on tour with this guy.
He ate rib-eyes for breakfast. We'd have,
he'd often have to revise for lunch and sometimes a whole time Hawk at night,
or maybe two more, rib-eyes little salty at some club soda, water, that's it,
people kept asking me that this can't be true. And I was like,
if he is secretly eating cookies in his hotel room, I don't know about it.
But from what I know, uh, he was keeping to it. And,
and I did see throughout the year that we were together on the road,
that he actually, his skin started looking better.
He said it fixed some stuff related to like oral hygiene.
And that I thought his hair looked even like a little thicker or something. Wow.
Um, do you, have you studied this at all? Do you sense, uh,
an imbalance there, but not about him specifically,
but just generally like when, when people do these,
what are seemingly sort of extreme versions? What you're talking about?
I think meat is, is very nutrient dense. Um, you know, there's certain,
I think people in the carnivore community, um, you know,
there's some debate about whether or not they're getting adequate amounts of
vitamin C or even optimal amounts of vitamin C, um,
which is found predominantly in, in, you can get it in,
you can get small amounts of vitamin C and fresh liver, raw, fresh liver,
but you got to eat raw, fresh liver to get it right for a carnivore, right.
By the way, I should mention that in the midst of all this, he took,
he had a physical for some insurance stuff and it's all his numbers.
He told me he came back fine. So just that in that way.
No, I think that meat is very healthy. Like I'm not, you know,
I think that there's a lot of confusion about the value of meat in a healthful
diet, in an environmentally friendly diet, um, or way of eating, I should say.
But, uh, but yeah, no, I'm a big, I'm a big advocate. I think a lot of people,
the people that I see tend to do best on the carnivore diet, because it's a,
it's a very extreme elimination diet is essentially what it is.
And it's also a very safe,
it's very hard to over-consume meat because protein is the most satiating
macronutrient. It's going to be more satiating than fat.
It's gonna be more satiating than carbs. So it's very difficult to overeat meat.
Um, so a lot of people,
what you'll see is they're going to end up losing weight.
And when you lose weight,
a lot of biomarkers that we associate with ill health tend to get
fixed, you know, high blood, you know, if you have high blood pressure,
it's gonna go down when you lose weight, um,
inflammatory markers and things like that.
So just losing weight is going to help you if you, if you are overweight. Um,
but also people with, uh, with inflammatory conditions,
with autoimmune conditions, what I've observed and in my conversations with,
uh,
people who are advocates of the carnivore diet and also medical doctors who are
advocates of the carnivore diet, um, that you're removing problematic compounds,
you know, uh,
plant-based compounds that can be allergenic for some people that can
induce, uh, you know, a form of mimicry,
which can aggravate an already confused immune system and cause an autoimmune
response in some people. So, um, that being said,
do I think that people need to, that, you know, it's, uh, it's,
it's a very difficult diet to adhere to.
And if I were still suffering from some kind of autoimmune condition,
I would probably give it a shot, but then I would try to reintegrate. I mean,
elimination diets are not meant to be, um, you know,
adhere to long-term you're supposed to like cut everything out and then
reintegrate one by one, um, you know,
these different food groups so that you can see what the actual source of your
problems is. Right. Um, so yeah, I don't know. I mean,
I've never tried it personally, but.
Yeah. Can we talk about the anti-inflammatory thing for a little bit?
So I don't remember last time I had you on,
which I think maybe is like a year and a half ago or so. Um,
I don't even know if I had talked about it publicly yet, but, uh,
a couple of years back, about five years ago,
I was getting my hair cut and my girl,
she told me that I was missing some chunks of hair.
And then it started spreading basically all over my head.
And at one point I had lost literally like 40% of my hair and I was doing like,
create ha I told you about this, even, even privately,
maybe I don't even remember if it was private or on the show, but anyway,
I was doing like crazy spray on stuff to be on camera and all this other stuff.
And I was doing steroids and then I went on some experimental stuff and I had a
really horrible reaction to that.
The one thing that started turning it around for me was when I started doing
more of a paleo diet, which I'm still doing, not fully,
I'm doing more of like a slow carb thing, but really just to,
to do the anti-inflammatory thing. And I've seen a change. I mean,
I've lost weight. I feel better, even the little things,
old basketball injuries that don't hurt as much. Um,
can you just talk about the inflammatory situation,
why you don't want to be inflamed all the time.
Chronic low grade inflammation to a forest fire occurring in the body.
And I mean, my focus, the brain sits directly downwind of that fire,
unfortunately, and inflammation is not a bad thing. Like, you know, it's a,
it's a life saving function of our immune systems and it's really designed by
nature to spot clean cuts, wounds, scrapes, bruises, um,
and you can feel it if you've ever sprained an ankle, the area gets, you know,
it gets hot, it starts swelling, you know, um, will engorge with blood.
And, uh, the same thing happens when you, um, you know,
if you have an infection like in, you know, in your body, you become inflamed.
And the problem today, I think is that,
uh, our immune systems are responding not to what they would have,
you know, for our ancestors,
but they're responding more to our diets and our lifestyle.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about lifestyles,
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.